so I think we're about time we ready to
start all right the doors are sealed
good morning everyone
I am Ryan Nowak and I'm here all the way
from Seattle Washington as part of the a
subpoena Corps team to talk to you all
today and I for whatever reason a lot of
the other Microsoft people or asp net
core people have been here talking about
something new something that's gonna be
released in 3.0 or something that's like
just released I'm doing something
different because I'm a developer I'm
not a p.m. I spend most of my time
writing code not traveling to
conferences or giving presentations or
writing slides it kind of just did my
best so I'm gonna be doing a little bit
of a deep dive and i'm calling this
lessons learned building asp net core so
a little bit about me I work on all of
these things so there's kind of a common
thread here which is frameworks and
stuff that users touch but I've kind of
gone on this journey from MVC and
routing to razor razor compiler to
Blazer to raise your components and
there's a couple other things in there
too but what I really want to focus in
on today is we're gonna be talking about
the history and the story of asp net
core MVC over the period of dotnet core
kind of dotnet core 1.0 going to 2.0
going to 2.1 and going to maybe a little
bit of 2.2 and then a little bit into
the future I'm going to be talking about
some of the new things that we've
introduced during this time period some
of the changes in the way that the team
has thought about things we're gonna
look at some extensibility as well and
show you some powerful things that you
can do along the way that you maybe
didn't know about or you didn't have
access to in previous versions of the
framework and then I'm gonna talk to
spend a little bit talking about 3.0
some of the think changes that we're
making to routing and how that story
sort of grows up so before we get into
that can I see a show of hands who is
using ASP net core has used asp net core
so there's a good number of people in
the room who has used asp net MVC 5 but
not asp net core okay so there's a small
there's a there's about a same
contingent set of people
so hopefully if you're not already
interested in asp net core you're not
already a little bit excited about it
you're gonna see some things today that
will hopefully make you a little bit
excited about it we're gonna be talking
about some of the things that we've kind
of done differently a little bit or
things that we've added a lot of what
you're gonna see today is going to be
about sort of fundamentals of
controllers and pages and routing and
those things and a lot of it's going to
seem new because it's additions from
nbc5 wrong direction so let's get right
into it I'm going to show you some stuff
and we're just gonna spend a little bit
of time talking about it so I have got
an app here and I'm gonna go ahead and
fire this up
and inside this app I have got probably
the most boring repetitive demo that
you've all seen a million times I have
built a really dumb to do application
and we're gonna look at three different
versions of that to do application I
mean a demo two of them I'm not gonna
demo the API because demoing API is cut
boring
we're gonna look at three different
versions of this to do application we're
gonna talk about some of the things that
make them different so I am going to go
to my - duze controller and what do I
need to do I need to give my talk I need
to then get some sleep and then I need
to adjust back to my time zone so those
are some of things that I need to do and
this is a basic to-do app that you've
seen about a million times I've got a
Razer pages version of this app as well
I can put something in here and I could
submit it and it adds to lists pretty
standard stuff pretty boring stuff let's
take a deeper look at what this code is
like so I have got this - duze
controller here and this is a
traditional sort of asp net court
controller if you have been doing MVC 5
in the past this is going to seem really
similar to you because it's pretty much
unchanged so one of the things that we
did when we built asp net core and this
is this was a decree of Scott Guthrie
you know all-powerful VP is that
basically controllers and views with a
few minor exceptions shall shall just
work like it needs to just work so for
the large part you're actually like
controller code from MVC 5 with a few
small caveats it's just the same I mean
you're not going to find anything very
different you
find some new api's and some new
concepts but you're not gonna find that
like very much has been taken out a few
things have been taken out that we
didn't really want to bring forward and
we felt like we had good reasons to do
but in general it's gonna look the same
so what let's let's talk about some
things that you've got here so this is
the sort of classic version and we've
got right away we've got dependency
injection in the constructor so one of
the things that the framework gives you
is you get we new up your class anything
that comes from dependency injection asp
net core has dependency injection built
in at a base level so one of the most
common things that you do is I'm in a
dependency inject my DB context okay not
that surprising other kinds of things
that you can do well we have routing we
route between these two methods and we
still have the same similar kind of
routing things to you're used to we have
the ability to disambiguate between
methods that are gonna match the same
URL based on HTTP verb which is what you
see here so another thing the framework
does for you so we see all these action
methods we wire them up to some route
table somewhere and then we pick the
best one we call this action selection
or routing we choose the one that's
going to match the request and then we
execute that not too different from what
you will have seen before
and since we are doing a traditional MVC
controller the really common thing that
you're going to do here is you are gonna
have a view you're gonna do some
database access you're gonna have a view
the view name is found by name it's by
convention and one of the most common
things that you're going to do is you're
going to create some kind of view model
if you're following best practices if
you're hip to that some people might not
like it you're going to create some kind
of view model that you're gonna pass to
your view you're going to instantiate
that and you're gonna pass your view so
kind of like the things that we see
going on here that are provided by the
framework is we've got activation we've
got routing we've got model binding down
here and we've got handling of results
or action results in this case so
something something else to point out
all air handling are all sort of like
validation error handling in an MVC
controller is explicit so like you are
responsible for handling errors I don't
know if that's ever but obvious to you
or if you've really thought about it in
the past maybe you just scaffolded code
or you copied from examples or
you maybe did learn this from
documentation but air handling in MVC
has always been explicit so if you want
to respond to the user and say hey you
had a validation error on this page you
you have to do that it's your
responsibility the other thing that I
would say because this is a traditional
controller I don't have anything else
here I just have these two actions and
this is an example of the post redirect
get pattern which is a really common web
pattern that's kind of just required for
the web to work correctly you show a
form you do a post you if you choose to
accept the post you redirect the user
somewhere else so that they can't hit
reload and just refresh the same thing
and submit it a million times we've all
seen this before
but you can have like any number of
other action methods that are unrelated
to this post reader gret post redirect
to get cycle that's comprised of these
two methods I just don't have them in my
example so let's look at a razor page
razor pages are something that were
introduced in a spinet core MVC 2.0 and
you're gonna notice that there's a lot
here that's different even though it's
kind of the same so we've got this on
yet and this on post method and they
fill the same two roles of what you saw
before so the on get is like I want to
show the form the on post is like
alright the user sent me the data now I
want to either accept it or not and then
either redirect them or show the same
form again with the validation errors so
we've taken this concept of the post
redirect get pattern and we've made it
kind of baked in and to be honest this
is what razor pages optimized for this
was a conscious decision on my part and
on Damien's part to say pages are for
these web for me kinda I realize I'm
will said web forms but they're for
forms and input processing and data
entry and crud and crud and those kind
of things where you want to show a form
accept the data and then redirect
somewhere else and the whole thing is
oriented around this post get redirect
you can do other things you can have
additional actions and things like that
as part of a page but it's not really
the focus right with controllers
controllers are super flexible and they
let you kind of structure things how you
want pages really optimize an orient for
this whole thing so to add to this like
if this because this is a razor page if
I had nothing to do in this on get
method I could just leave it out
and it doesn't matter it would always
just render the view if I didn't accept
post backs on this page I could just
leave that out and it doesn't matter I
don't need any of that stuff for it to
be a page so it kind of assumes that
you're going to scale that way you're
doing web pages that have a page focused
lifecycle and we're gonna add some
initialization logic add some post logic
but we're still within that framework of
post yet redirect proposed to rewrite
get sorry another thing to note here
validation and dealing with the results
of validation still explicit why is it
explicit well because in a UI you need
to present that error information to the
user so even though you might just do
the boilerplate like initialize the page
and show it again kind of thing it's
still we need to put a place in the code
where you can put your air-handling
logic because you got to figure out how
you're gonna get whatever information
that you want to present to the user
when you show them that they failed or
like they had a validation problem the
other thing about this that's kind of
neat is we talked about things that the
framework provides you there are some
things here that are common like
activation in common or activation and
routing are still here right we're still
going to create your page we still have
dependency injection we still have
routing but it's a little bit different
we got slightly different rules and
conventions but it mostly accomplishes
the same thing but the handling of
results is totally different because
pages are optimized around the case
where everything you do is going to
result in the user going to some razor
View at some point so like this on get
method for instance the action result is
totally implied you don't have to do
anything to show the page in fact you
have to do something if you don't want
to show the page so because we assume
that the common case is that you're
gonna want to keep users in this UI
that's what we optimize for and we make
it sort of the default thing to do now
let's do something else or let's look at
something else
this is API controller API controller is
something that we introduced in MVC 2.1
an API controller is kind of like you
can think about your MVC controller
that's like good at everything and your
page which is optimized for post
redirect get views HTML API controllers
are optimized for something completely
different
so we still have activation we still
have di and constructors
we still have routing it's really
similar to what we do for traditional
controllers but we're optimizing for
completely different things so one of
the things that we're optimizing for is
we're optimizing for open API our
swagger who's used open API or swagger
so it looks like about a third to a half
so one of the big challenges with open
API or swagger is well you got to have
all these features or all these
behaviors documented of your API so if
you think about like whizz doll or so
for some of these older technologies
like that like imagine if you could
write a REST API and then you could just
have like a document or like a spec like
a contract file for what your API is
supposed to do in theory that's
something that's great to do with rest
because we're doing c-sharp and because
we're strongly-typed we're putting some
of that information in the return type
I'm not going to go incredibly deep on
this topic there was some of it talked
about in Damian's talks if you haven't
seen some of the things we're doing
there lately I'm courage to go watch
Damion Edwards talk on on t2 from
earlier in the week but know that that's
part of the API controller story is
we're optimizing for the assumption that
you are building an API you might care
about the this open API thing how much
of a complete story and how close to a
default good experience can we get you
without you having to do work to do it
one of the other things that you're
going to notice here speaking of return
types or sort of results of things is
that you see that there's not any
validation error handling here and the
reason why that is is we've done it for
you
so with API controller one of the things
that you get for free and you can turn
it off if you don't want it is you get
automatic handling of validation errors
without having to do anything and the
reason what are some of the reasons why
we do that well in contrast to like a
website with a website you've got to
gather a lot of information that you
want to present to the user if they've
made a mistake or they entered something
incorrectly with an API you probably
want to optimize something different you
probably want to have all of your API
endpoints behave consistently with
respect to errors and you probably don't
really need to put much logic in there
you've already run validation you
basically want to return to the customer
or the user whoever called your API
somebody
by some JSON blob that says these were
the validation rules that failed or
something like that so you've just done
it for you because it's it's sort of
just clutter for api's you you don't
really tend to need it too much so jump
back to my slides here and what we're
really talking about is kind of the
evolution of MVC or the evolution of
these programming models we sort of have
the the progenitor which is original
controllers and original MVC which is
like yeah I can do whatever you want but
it doesn't really bias you in any way or
another and then you have these things
like pages and API controllers that bias
you towards certain scenarios so like
our traditional controller as we said
like it eats everything does everything
you can do whatever you want but it's
kind of verbose because you have to be
really explicit about a bunch of things
it's also not really changed because
it's kind of just classic you know it's
it's an old it's an old Cadillac or
something like that at this point that's
kind of just is what it is and it's
gonna stay that way forever it's not
really an area where we're looking to
add more bells and whistles it's stable
it's well known it's not broken it's
working pretty well
razor pages jumping all the way over to
the right has got simplified routing and
is optimized for a particular set of UI
focused scenarios we assume that you are
doing the common things for views
something that I didn't point out that I
probably should have is in our
controller example we're constructing a
view viewmodel object and passing that
into the view in a razor page the like
page handler class is the view model
object you don't necessarily have to
create a separate object if you want to
we give you a place to pass state to the
view because we assume you're going to
do it we rip that off from rails by the
way which would not be the only thing we
ripped off from rails looking at API
controller in contrast it's for REST API
is it's open for it's optimized for open
API or whatever kinds of other things
might come along in that space
it has opinions about precise parameter
binding and other things like that we're
gonna spend a little bit of more time
talking about that later because I'm
gonna show you some things and it's got
that automatic uniform error handling it
automatically does things for you
because instead of tailoring each error
experience towards who's the customer
who's trying to sign up for my email
form it's well we want a document what
format we return airs in from this API
so that our customers can make sense of
them because our customer is a computer
this all kind of makes sense I'm seeing
seeing some nods of agreement I also
want to say I think of these three
things that kind of lump pages into the
same category and I've got my own
definition I'm going to call it a
controller like because I'm being
upfront about the fact that this is not
the traditional definition of a
controller I'm instead talking about the
structure of the code and how its
implemented rather than what role it
fills in architecture so I would refer
to a controller like as a handler that
instantiates an object calls a method
communicating inputs through method
arguments and outputs through method
return values so it's basically this
pattern we activate we're out which
means we choose which method it's going
to go to we bind parameters which means
we're going to have some data to pass
into the controller like and then we
interpret the result which in our case
is a command object or an action result
I think that this is a useful definition
because this just worked so well in
c-sharp and other object-oriented
languages so Ruby's got this pattern
Java's got this pattern that's got this
pattern I'm sure a lot of other
languages and platforms have this
pattern because if you're doing
object-oriented programming it just
works so well these are kind of the
tools that you have available to you and
when I think about designing features
are building new things into the
framework I think about the design space
in terms of those things those are the
some of the things that users can do in
their code so if we can respond to what
you put in your code or if we can
optimize what you have to put in your
code it could be really beneficial to
you it could make your life easier
it could make things less error-prone so
let's step back and take a slightly
bigger picture I haven't shown the start
up class of this application but if
you've done any asp net core before this
kind of thing should be pretty familiar
to you everything that we have talked
about so far is in that ugly yellow blob
so we've got all these other middleware
here we've got developer exception page
we've got exception handler we've got
some HTTP kinds of things we've got
static file serving we've got a gdpr
thing
and then we have use MVC use MVC is
actually what we call the used router
middleware and it's what hooks routing
up to the middleware pipeline so once
you get inside of middleware
think of middleware as like this
sequential pipeline it's a bunch of
handlers for handlers for handlers for
handlers for handlers and request
processing proceeds through this chain
until it gets to routing and routing is
a branch routing makes a decision and
says we are going that way and we're
going to home index or we are going that
way and we're going to the to dues page
the action invoker is all the stuff that
we've seen before which is like alright
I got a run your code I got to run your
page I got to run your your API
controller how MVC interacts with
routing is well we have to figure out
what's in your app and we have to
initialize a route table with all that
data so that routing can make the right
decisions so would it be cool if we
could check out what that's like and
spoiler spoiler alert we can check that
out so I'm going to boot up this app
again and what I've done in here is I've
created an action on a controller just
doing a normal thing that's going to
grab some MVC framework data and I've
just formatted it for a little bit of a
nicer display so you can see in here
basically all of these actions that
exist and I'm gonna look for I'm going
to scroll past some stuff and I look for
that first controller that we talked
about so here's our first controller
that we talked about that plain old
vanilla controller you can see we've got
the index action this one's the get one
I can tell that because it has no
parameters and it's got some filters
around it so what are filters you
probably may have heard of filters
before but the way I like to think about
filters and the way I want to introduce
them to you is there just middleware for
MVC so filters are like you've got that
middleware pipeline that we looked at
before that's like okay I'm gonna run
air handling and then I'm going to run
authorization and then I'm going to run
files and then I'm going to run routing
filters are just middleware for your
actions and controllers and it's this
big complicated beast it's got a bunch
of different stages and things like that
but really what you need to know about
is that there are middleware for your
controller and there are some filters
here that are built-in by default I'm
going to talk a little bit about more
what these are in
woman here is our post action and I can
tell that this is our post action
because it's got a single parameter down
here and that's this to do model and it
says binding in foam model binding what
binding info model binding means to me
it's terrible name and you can blame me
for it cuz I created it but what model
binding means to me in this context is
it means be as flexible as possible
because when we think about how our UI
applications work we don't really care
that much about being precise about like
where the data came from did it come
from the query string did it come from
the route data was it part of a form
post like as long as it's gonna get you
there you're you're pretty much fine
with it and that's alright because you
might have multiple forms that pose to
the same endpoint or something like that
you want a certain degree of flexibility
when you're doing UI programming because
you don't necessarily care down at the
bottom here we've got our to Do's page
and you'll notice that there is only a
single action here it's not actually two
separate things it's one thing that
makes a decision when it runs am i doing
a GAD or am i doing a post there's some
somewhat complicated architectural
reasons in there but basically the way
to think about it is because pages can
be recompiled we have to sort of like
have the branching logic inside the page
we don't know what the compiled type of
the page is going to look like and what
methods it has and what filters it has
and all those kinds of things we don't
know those things when we build the
route table so I actually did some like
workarounds to get this data because if
you looked at what's in the route table
the what's called the action descriptor
for a page actually doesn't have any of
this information it only is a thing that
can be routed to and then later we
create the actual thing because pages
can be recompiled
and also we don't read them we don't
compile all the pages on startup or we
don't have to it's not a requirement of
the system it's actually a requirement
the other way but this is mostly going
to be the same as our controller because
it kind of does the same things let's
look at our API controller
Wow so I'm looking at just the post
action here I'm gonna skip the get one
because it's less interesting than this
but you'll notice that there's like all
kinds of filters here like it's filters
going bananas the other thing that there
is is there's this body binding info
body now what is that so binding info
body is a default parameter source
convention that is part of the API
controller construct so rather than
model binding which is like I want to be
flexible I want to collect all the data
I want to shove it all in one pile and
roll around in it this is going to be
very precise and I'm saying that I
expect the body of this to do item to
come from Jason that's going to get
deserialized for the body now why would
you care about this well it's the
opposite of a UI controller you actually
want to define where your data is coming
from and what the requests that are past
your API should look like because you
want to give your customers who are
other computers or other services or
other teams at your company or maybe
even external people a consistent and
stable and well-documented contract so
one of the things that comes with API
Explorer is that the binding behavior is
by default are sort of optimized for the
kinds of things that you might
reasonably do rather than expecting you
to mark this up yourself so to look at
that a little bit if I went to this API
controller I could do something like
this and changes are not allowed when
code is still running I'm very sorry
visual studio I could do something like
this and I could be very explicit about
where this is coming from but because
it's an API API controller I don't have
to do that it's assumed because it's the
most common thing that you probably
wanted to do anyway so I'm just going to
revert that cool so hopefully that's a
little bit of useful information the way
to think about it we've got all these
sort of filters and all these different
things that we collect we've got the
parameter info we've got the routing
info we build this big table of actions
at startup time and we throw that into
routing and that's kind of how stuff
gets to your code and this is a diagram
of the invoker it's been simplified a
little bit I talked about how filters
are complicated this is how they're
complicated there are lots of different
lots of different ways that they
now I want to change gears a little bit
and I want to sort of distill what we
just talked about and think about how I
think about moving frameworks forward
how I think about our role in being your
partner and helping you build things so
to me what makes a framework so
different from a library is that like a
library you call this method it does a
thing maybe it reads a JSON file maybe
it writes something to disk maybe it
resizes an image something like that it
does one task and you're generally as
the application author you're in control
of what's happening whereas like a
framework well does this right it's got
all these little points to wire up
features it's got all these callbacks
it's got pipelines it's got
extensibility points and ultimately we
have this concept called inversion of
control which you might have heard in
the context of dependency injection but
that's just one meaning of it inversion
of control just generally means like
alright you wrote the application but
we're the ones calling your method right
like it's not your code a hundred
percent it's maybe your code about 60
percent or about forty percent and
that's kind of the gist of inversion of
control is you're gonna create something
we're gonna be the ones responsible for
calling it or sort of plugging you in so
what's risky about this or what's bad
about this is like well well what if we
have a bug and I'll be honest with you
we do we have bugs what if we have a bug
what if we don't call your code what if
we don't pass the right methods or pass
the right arguments what if we call
methods in a different sequence than we
did before or like what if we didn't
load your DLL what if we're not routing
to your controller what do you do if we
have a bug like what's your workaround
sadly a lot of the time there's not a
workaround or it's gonna be some awful
arcane thing that you're gonna log an
issue on github and I'm gonna respond
with 200 lines of code and I'm gonna say
hey make a class call this paste it into
your project wire it up to the solution
wire it up to your dependency injection
and we'll patch this as soon as I can so
so those are some of the problems with
having a bug in the framework some of
the risks with having a bug in framework
we also provide a lot of extensibility
and everywhere that we've got this rich
extensibility
is another sort of like risk for your
application if we don't do our job so
like if we broke something that you
depend on let's say you wrote a model
binder because you need to parse some
data or you want to you want to
automatically model bind a parameter
from your database or something like
that which is super common thing people
love to do like what if we break you
what if what if asp net core to one
works great and asp net core to two does
not work so great like how do you get
past that we vote we've erected this
very like challenging barrier for you to
get through the other thing here
frameworks have opinions and opinions
change so like we're doing this open API
thing now our automatic error responses
are something called problem details or
RFC 90 807 like what if that's not the
thing anymore in five years like is your
application still going to be around in
five years so you probably do care about
this stuff right because like if you if
you like that and you're still using it
and we say but but nobody's using that
anymore we want to get rid of it like
you still have to get some path right
and even if your path involves you
changing code and moving forward like
how can we make that path as seamless
and as smooth as possible we also have
with something like API Explorer at
least in my opinion because so much of
your application is our code in our
library and our behavior we have a
significant opportunity to add value to
you because the the mix the mix is just
the mix is just a little bit bigger in
our favor a little bit of time so we're
like we can make your life a lot easier
with libraries to kind of stay in their
box and do what they do but with a
framework it's like it's like
superpowers at least that's how I think
about it and then and then lastly how
does a team come up with a strategy that
preserves our ability to keep working on
the framework keep making improvements
and keep making changes so I want to
show you some real bugs that we have had
and some real problems that we have
fixed and how these issues can be kind
of kind of vexing really like I think
when you see hopefully when you see some
of these bugs you'll agree with me that
it's not necessarily as straightforward
for us as like well we'll just fix the
bug because there are some other
concerns that come up when we start
talking about functional bugs and
frameworks or change
and behavior frameworks so I'm going to
use that term a lot breaking change of
behavior so I think there's a good talk
that John is doing John skeet is doing
next that's going to be better than
anything that I can say about it but the
world is broken down into changes and
breaking changes and all kinds of
different changes and the way that I
think about it is that every change can
be a breaking change to somebody and
there's different kinds you can break
source compatibility you can break
binaries or you can break behavior and
I'm really going to focus on breaking
changes in behavior because I think I've
got some pretty good examples here so
here is an example page that I wrote
with some really hacky fetch stuff and
this is gonna do some asynchronous data
posts to the server to do some things I
haven't shown you any of the code yet to
know what it's doing yet I'm just going
to describe it and you're gonna see
results down here in this kind of low
contrast text box at the bottom this is
about as good as my UI stills get if
you've seen the blazer stuff the Razr
component stuff I maybe wrote some of
those application parts it did not write
any of the UI Steve Sanderson did that
so I am going to post to this controller
and uh-oh I've got a problem I hit an
exception so I have written my own input
formatter I don't know if anybody in the
audience has ever written an input
formatter before but an input for matter
is like the thing that DC realizes
requests bodies so if you're reading
Jason you've got a JSON input format or
if you're reading XML you probably have
one of the two XML serialization format
errs reading that if you wanted to hook
up UML to asp net core you would take a
yamo serialization library and then you
would use an input formatter to plug it
in so it's the place where we integrate
so cool so I have an exception who
thinks they knows what this exception is
going to do is it going to is it going
to crash the application is it going to
give me yellow screen of death is it
going to give me back a 500 graceful
think about it in your brain I'm not
gonna ask for participation but think
about in your brain what this is going
to do or what you'd like it to do if
your formatter was throwing an exception
and and keep in mind this is an assembly
load exception and that's on purpose so
I'm gonna continue and we get it we get
a message here saying oh an error
occurred we're real sorry about that
and I think I failed to reset my demo
but I'm not I'm gonna check that real
quick because I might have made a
mistake here
but anyway I'm gonna keep explaining
while I keep looking we had a bug yes I
did I forgot to reset my demo my bad
we had a bug in asp net core 1x and 2x
and so on where if an input formatter
through an exception for any reason at
all it would get swallowed by the
framework and it would get turned into a
normal validation error so there's
actually good reason for that but it was
still bad so here we are again I throw
an exception in my formatter and I get
this generic the input was not valid
method so the problem is the
infrastructure that calls input for
matters swallows all exceptions just
eats them all and turns them into
validation errors and the reason why is
that a lot of the built-in serializers
in dotnet XML serializer and XML data
contract serializer throw an exception
when data is invalid and they have no
other way to report that the data was
invalid so if you posted invalid XML to
the server you would really prefer for
that to come back as a 400 not a 500 we
work with a lot of customers that have
monitoring services and if you have a
monitoring service in production or you
have an IT organization that uses a
monitoring service to watch things or if
you get alerting from your monitoring
service you know that you don't want
500s occurring in production because
even if they're sort of benign it makes
it hard for you to catch real problems
so we you start getting pinged by people
that are sort of like I'm seeing all
these 500s and seeing all these crashes
and it's like well reporting an error
correctly and saying this is bad data
versus this is a crash like it's
actually really important in these
production kind of scenarios even though
it doesn't crash the app so we had a bug
and if you were with us through asp net
core 1.0 or through the DNX days and i'm
sure that there is at least one you know
DNX
og here he's laughing probably it it
could he's trying
Ribit just remembering it I think the
thing that he's remembering specifically
is that in asp net core 100 it could
have been really hard for you to get the
right set of assemblies and
your application like the right versions
of assemblies in your application we've
kind of clean that up but if you had
that kind of problem one of the places
that you were very likely to blow up was
reading the request body because it
could be the first time that a bunch of
those assemblies are getting loaded to
do like i/o so we got this like rash of
issues reported by people that were like
well I'm getting this this invalid model
exception and I have no idea why
and then I we tell them well this is
where you look to look at that data and
they look at that data and they say oh
but that error has an exception
associated with it and the exception is
like invalid type load exception or
something like that and it's like oh
holy crap like that's really bad right
so we're silencing all these really bad
application deployment and configuration
problems and representing them as like a
validation failure which is really
really bad right and the reason why is
because we have to work with some
libraries that use that exception as
their success path so this gets to
customers before we realize we have a
problem so what do you do because like
it is a breaking change of behavior to
this interface right this is a somewhat
common somewhat high profile
extensibility API and we have this
behavior before where we just handle all
exceptions we just eat them and we turn
them into model hairs I've got another
cool bug here so I have got a controller
that is model binding and enum value and
that enum value has got three values can
be dog cat or fish so I put in dog here
it's gonna say everything's fine if I
put in cat or fish here it's gonna say
that everything is fine cool if I put in
something that's out of range like let
me put in unicorn or unicron both good
but I know that I don't have a unicorn
element of this enum and it's going to
tell me that it's gonna say that's not
valid that's good that's what you'd
expect that's what you'd want cool what
if I put in 0 well 0 works because 0 is
a valid member of the Cena and some
serializers Jason net does this in some
cases some serializers will serialize
enum values as their integer equivalents
that's totally valid right it's
just a different way of representing the
same information okay fine
so my values of this a number zero one
and two what if I put in a different
number what that works it does work so
the reason why is because an integer or
an enum this enum in particular is
represented as an integer and dotnet is
very happy to convert some arbitrary
integer into your enum even though it
doesn't match one of the enum values
that you've defined because it is
possible the language allows it it's a
technically possible thing and so the
normal code paths that you go down for
enum conversions don't enforce this
they'll let you convert some random enum
value you can even make this like a
negative number like it can just be any
number that can be converted to an in 32
will work so like we did what dotnet
does we expose that over the Internet
and then we found later it's like oh
this is a bad default for the web right
this is a bad default for our users
another thing that comes up here
I want to validate some data we have an
email signup list I have a required
validator on this thing so I submit my
email address that is my email address
you can email me if you want I submit I
submit my my email request to sign up
for this mailing list and it validates
it and everything is fine cool let's do
something else what if I submit an empty
I have a required validator on here oops
that works the reason why that works is
that you'll be blown you might be blown
away by this I might blow some minds but
MVC never had support for this Web API
didn't need it it was not a feature we
had so like validation attributes on
parameters directly which is what my
code is doing I have a string email
address with a required attribute on it
it's legal the code compiles the data
annotations attribute which is from the
dotnet BC all data annotations library
that's been around forever allows being
put on parameters but we just never had
this behavior it was never present in
MVC it was not present in MVC one it was
not present in MVC two and like if your
mind is blown by that you probably are
thinking like well surely you can fix
this like why wouldn't you want
that everybody would want that it seems
obvious that that should work and the
answer is well we we felt the same way
we really wanted this to work as well so
we added it so I'm not gonna I'm not
going to show the second half of this
which is that we were able to fix the
bugs just for time but basically we were
able to fix all these things and the way
that we're able to fix all these things
is that we were able to come up with a
strategy for how we want to manage this
and how we want to manage change going
forward so a couple of things that we
thought about just just saying like
semver and like semver means we can make
breaking changes I think it's not good
enough
like you can picture like if you seen
The Hunchback of Notre Dom and you could
picture like running into the church
yelling like semver like that's not good
enough like we can't just say to our
users like we will break everything we
will change everything in 3.0 it's gonna
have all these subtle little things in
it that's not quite enough that's a
little bit too harsh we could say we're
gonna just fix these things we're gonna
just fix these things right that's not
great either because it only works for
really small issues we can't really just
fix the parameter validation thing
because it affects a bunch of
extensibility we can't really just fix
the exception formatter thing because
it's a breaking change so you get in the
situation as a team or as a product
owner where it's like well we can't
change this stuff because it's too risky
it's too expensive it hurts our
customers too much because all of these
problems require a code change and a
redeployment from our customers so not
only do you have to deploy upgrade to
the new version of asp.net core and you
have to like deploy it somewhere you got
to test everything to find these
problems including invalid data and
that's why they're so risky second thing
we could add more options or settings we
could take all these different things
and we gonna say we could make all of
these things optional behaviors that you
can choose if you think that enum thing
really makes sense to you you can leave
it the old way if you like the new
behavior you want it to be validated
because you're saying you you opt into
that the big problem with that big
problems with that again only works for
small stuff with a really minimal impact
and - when we add options they have to
be off by default because otherwise
you're back at breaking changes so at
best you can give people that know
have a problem with workaround which is
not a great you know it's kind of the
minimum you could do so what we did
instead is we did this thing called
compatibility switches and you can think
of it like a hybrid of sort of all those
options if you have looked at your
templates or you have looked at your
application at some point in your life
since 2.0 and you're doing asp net core
you have probably seen something like
this compatibility version 2.0 and you
can see that we've got 2.1 2.2 we've got
all these different compatibility
versions and it's it's as simple as it
sounds right so every time we fix the
bug or we make a small change like this
we do that in some release that fix that
change in behavior gets a switch that's
associated with the version of that
release so for you as an application
author you take your app you upgrade
from two oh two to one you replace the
binaries right you get the package
references two to one you follow all the
migration guidance the migration call it
guidance calls out the things that have
changed that are associated with
compatibility switches because we think
you should know about them and you can
leave that compatibility version at 2.0
for a while if you want like you can run
the two one binaries with with the two O
behaviors and that's basically what
compatibility switches give you you get
to take these things at your own pace
and you're not blocked from getting like
new features necessarily or new stuff
that requires 2.1 or performance
improvements or minor bug fixes or
platform upgrades so it gives you like a
smoother cliff to upgrade and integrate
all these things the other thing that we
do here is that on these options objects
I have to get I'm gonna have to get used
to typing on this pedestal so you guys
are gonna have to bear with me we have
got options for all the things that we
add compatibility switches so this is
that exception input format or one so if
you want to upgrade everything but for
some reason you're like locked on this
one you can leave it alone you can
revert to the old behavior and you can
micromanage these things if you want to
I don't know many people who do but it's
there in case you need it the other
thing about this is that we declare we
sort of declare amnesty for ourselves on
major versions so we still can we still
intend to get rid of old busted stuff we
still intend to make MVC the best
version of MVC moving forward
but we want to give you like a really
nice roadmap to move forward with these
things and a really nice way to take
these upgrades and chunks we also
reserve the right to leave old behaviors
behind if they make sense to leave
behind as options doing this
compatibility switch thing is good from
our point of view because it gives us a
chance to get feedback from people and
then if a lot of users are like well I
really need this thing then great we're
gonna leave that thing and you can think
about you can think about which option
is better for you we'll decide a default
but if you like the old behavior you can
keep it in some cases so that's the
compatibility switch that's kind of the
journey that we've been on now why don't
we have them in other areas of the stack
we don't have the other we don't have
compatibility switches yet in other
areas of the stack like in the HTTP
layer simply because it hasn't come up
we haven't felt like there are issues
that are sort of worthy of it in those
parts of the stack because they're not
as framework II and the kinds of
problems and solutions you have if
you're a user are not not as thorny to
work through but I'm not saying never we
might do it if there are good scenarios
for it now I want to show some more code
so we're going to talk about filters in
a little bit more depth and filters are
this like power feature of MVC now I
showed you that list of actions before
and we saw all those filters that are on
all those things in particular API
controller had like a million filters on
it and we're gonna examine a couple
ideas for filters a couple things sort
of about their nature and hopefully
you'll learn some stuff or get inspired
by this so you notice in this some bugs
thing if I revert if I'm now that I'm
into two I'm just gonna run it again
while I'm talking about this now that
I'm running into two if I hit this
crashing JSON exception an input
formatter case which I want to crash
because it's an assembly load it's a
deployment failure I am gonna get a
friendly Jason error so here's my
exception here's my exception again I
get this friendly JSON message here well
this is coming from my code and this is
coming from a filter that I wrote so if
I come down here to this errors folder I
have got this JSON exception filter
attribute and if I look at where that is
applied and I realize that's kind of
small
I have got this on the bad format or
controller so what you can learn about
this is that well it kind of does the
obvious thing I've got this attribute on
the controller which means I've applied
this behavior to all the actions on my
controller if I wanted to apply this
behavior to say my whole app there's a
way to do that too which we'll see in a
little bit but looking at this guy a
little bit more I'm gonna handle
exceptions that come from these actions
I'm going to respond with some message
with some severity level and I'm gonna
put that an object result and give it a
500 which is basically saying like
you're gonna write this to Jay as JSON
or XML I want to do something with this
severity thing so I've got the default
I've got the default sort of setting
here for severity set at nah relax it's
okay like could I change this setting
well sure I could I could modify the
code right but could I build a system
such that this severity level can be
like toggled up and down for individual
actions one thing that I could do is I
could make this like a parameter of this
filter that's kind of obvious right but
what if the severity is a part of like
multiple filters or like multiple
systems need to interact with this
severity I don't want a couple it to the
exception handler if I'm using that
severity also for logging and different
things like that I might need to use it
for multiple places so I want to build
it in a way that's D couple how can I do
that
well this filter is an example of
something that I'd refer to as an active
filter meaning that it implements an
interface it does something so this on
exception method hooks up to the invoker
and is part of a life cycle to kind of
you know do stuff around your controller
or like meta program your controller but
I can also have filters that are what I
refer to as passive filters or as
metadata and as an example of that I
have created this JSON severity X
attribute now the only thing that you
really need to know about this the only
thing that makes this special is this I
filter metadata and I exception severity
so this I filter metadata is an NBC type
and it basically says to the framework
when you see this on a controller or on
a global or somewhere
I want you to retain that information so
that I can get it later so if you've
ever find yourself like writing filters
where you do reflection over your own
code what attribute is applied to what
there's a better way to do that and I
mean I'm going to show you that right
now so if I come to the startup class of
this one thing that I can do is I can
add this thing as a filter so a filter
is add and I'm making it a global filter
say exception severity attribute and I'm
gonna say that the severity is going to
be someone should look into that because
somebody really should look into that
I'm gonna add this as a global filter
which means that for any action in my
application I should be able to look at
that I should be able to look at the set
of filters or the set of data associated
with actions and I should be able to see
this policy applied to it or this
metadata applied to it and then the
other change that I have to make is here
inside my exception I have to get that
data so I can do something like this I
can save our policy equals two contacts
dot find effective policy and I'm gonna
put in the eye exception severity
interface so I'm basically going to look
at the collection of metadata for the
current action and I'm gonna see do we
have a policy apply to this action that
sets the exception severity and then
inside here I'm gonna use that because I
should probably use it and we might not
have one so question mark dot and we're
going to use the severity and then fall
back to this just just relax nobody
cares about the severity of this thing
then it's probably not that important
and then to sort of prove that this
works I'm going to go to my bad my bad
controller here and I'm going to put a
exception severity on my controller
we're on this action so I can put my
exception severity here assumption
severity severity and we'll say that
this is this is on fire this is really
important so if I run this again what's
going to happen is I've got this sort of
default of like everything is cool
applied to everything but then I've I've
overridden that meta
I've specified a more specific metadata
for just an action so if I run this now
I get my exception like I expected and
then I get down here and it says that
everything is on fire which is just what
I wanted so filters already have this
kind of like scoping policy or this
scoping behavior where like if you put
something on an action it's considered
more specific than something on a
controller which is more specific than
something that's global they're all
kinds of ways to control the ordering of
things and filters but you can do that
to build these systems that do metadata
or kind of like build your own
extensibility into things in a way that
works the way that's copyist if you
think about how you'd want that to
behave right an attribute on the method
is more specific than an attribute on
the class and so on so what else can we
do with this well if I wanted to let's
say my application really takes off
because people love this app and let's
say that I have got a bunch of places
that I have this JSON exception filter
sprinkled around that's kind of annoying
because what if I forget to leave it off
then my error handling is incorrect what
can I do about that
well one thing that I could do about
that is I could come back to the startup
and I could also make this a global
filter so I'm gonna add that filter here
as well Chason exception filter
attribute and now this should be fired
this should be wired up to all the
actions so can anybody guess the problem
with this well the problem with this is
I've applied it at the global level so
if there's any actions that I don't want
Jason handling for or I don't want to
treat errors as Jason like say an action
that's supposed to be used from the UI
then it's going to give me the JSON
error even though I didn't want it
because it's applied globally so could
we do something smarter and the answer
is you can you can do some of the kinds
of things that we do internally I want
to introduce something now called
application model I'm gonna move kind of
quickly through this but if there's
anything that you take from this this is
how features like API controller that
are really powerful and smart are built
is for us through sort of a combination
of filters and something called the
application model so I'm gonna nuke this
because we already know the problem with
that and I'm going to come back here say
options dot convened
add and I've already written this new
JSON exception filter convention and how
this is going to work is I define this
convention and I've made it a controller
model Convention which means it's going
to evaluate once per controller in the
app and what I get here is I get this
thing called a controller model and this
has got a bunch of different junk on it
so it's got the list of actions and it's
got models for each action it's got the
controller name the controller type it's
got the collection of attributes so you
don't have to query them yourself if you
don't want to it has got the set of
filters it's got a property bag that you
can dump things in and it's got all the
routing information as well so what I
can do with this is I could apply my
Jason behavior to just my AP eyes and I
could do that by saying something like
this is API controller controller and I
kind of duplicated some logic from the
framework here we should probably make
this available but I'm basically saying
if you've got the API controller
attribute or if it's applied at the
assembly level then it's an API
controller so if is API controller
control our filters add new Jason
exception filter attribute and this has
done the same thing as we did before of
I'm gonna apply this Jason air handling
policy but it's just going to be limited
to your api's and it's kind of like out
of sight out of mind right like if
you're the if you're the person who
manages infrastructure for your team and
a lot of other people sort of manage the
code or work on different parts of the
application like it's a good way to kind
of like make sure that policies like
this are being applied uniformly and are
being like rolled out in ways that make
sense for your team and kind of manage
centrally so think about doing some of
these things if it appeals to you so
when you look at like API controller API
controller that attribute is effectively
just that code I showed you times like
five where we say we have a bunch of
conventions that say is this an API
controller if it is an API controller
register a filter that filter does
something like automatically respond
with your validation errors so there's
kind of a difference there that gets
drawn out pretty quickly between
something like Razer pages which has a
lot of special behaviors but those
behaviors are built into the framework
they're kind of baked
versus something like API controller
it's just a controller all those
behaviors are layered on top all done
with conventions and filters very
powerful stuff I'm gonna quickly move
through some more slides because I'm a
little bit behind where I want it to be
I want to show you a little bit more
stuff so let's talk about middleware and
filters real quick middleware are this
pipeline right there this decorator
pattern or this chain of command pick
whichever description you like archana
responsibility you run logic you call
max to run logic you call next it's got
an async before/after pattern run code
before something run code after
something filters essentially do the
same thing but there are more different
ways to do it more stages more
information about MVC in there if we
could compare those they're both ordered
pipelines
they're both terminal in the sense they
both can be terminal meaning that they
allow you to short-circuit right so do
you think about a security middleware
it's gonna short-circuit you say you're
not authorized go away they can mutate
the request in response to effect what
happens after them or on the way out but
then they start to become different
middleware all happened before routing
and so they don't know anything about
routing they don't know anything about
your actions they can't look at your
filters they can't look at your metadata
they can't do anything like that they
are global filters can be scoped they
can be applied with conventions they can
be applied statically at all different
levels of granularity middleware since
they all appear in your startup code in
a simple like kind of single order it's
very easy to reason about the order that
they run in whereas filters like the
ordering between them is kind of opaque
right it's complicated there are many
phases and the tools that you have for
ordering them are pretty poor middleware
supports many things that filters do we
have many implementations that are
common between filters and middleware
like cores like response caching but we
also have some things that are just
implemented in filters like
authorization there has never been an
authorization middleware in MVC if you
want to secure a middleware and have it
check that the user is logged in sorry
you're gonna have to write some code
because we don't provide an
authorization middleware so we've kind
of siloed ourselves here by putting
bunch of things in both places in
duplicating the code we put a bunch of
things in MVC where they're tied to MVC
and that's really the only way to use
them but there are more frameworks than
MVC there are good they're good
community projects like Carter or like
Nancy FX and there are other frameworks
in Microsoft ship like signal R or like
soon to be Razer components right and we
have the sort of challenge of like well
if we build signal R we built something
like that what features do we have to
duplicate now inside of this thing and
provide different ways of getting at
because it's separate and we can't reuse
what's in MVC
so wouldn't it be cool if we had a way
to take the best of both of these things
so now we're talking a little bit about
3.0 and if you've heard about end point
routing and you see me you know the
preview to announcement blog post
anything like that endpoints are a new
primitive that's part of the middleware
pipeline and inside the middleware it's
it's like the middleware pipeline but
it's got routing as well so you can
think of it as like if middleware had
access to routing information if
middleware had access to filters if
middleware could do all those things
that they could do so in this model
endpoints a new primitive and it's
basically a middleware plus metadata
it's a middleware that you can ask
things about what are your interests
where did you come from what are you
doing here what's your course policy you
know that kinds of kinds of small talk
kinds of things in this mode you've got
middleware acting as the active filters
so things that do stuff our middleware
and the metadata themselves are the
passive filters meaning that they just
apply data to things and we think that
that combines the best of the two
systems and a lot of this stuff is still
being developed and is still sort of
being worked towards here and I am
basically out of time so I'm going to
kind of introduce this and I might show
one quick demo but I am basically going
to be out of time here so let's take a
look at this future application that
I've built and this is based on preview
too so I have got this use routing
method and it's going to look kind of
similar to what you might have today
where you've got MVC you've got some
routes for MVC but you've also can have
random lambdas you also can have a
random function here you also can have
health checks
and it's all just routing now wouldn't
it be cool if you could apply metadata
to these things so what if I could say
on my health check I'm going to add my
Jason exception policy which is similar
to the thing that we just showed in last
thing what if I could take that Jason
exception handler behavior and I could
attach that to a health check what if I
could take this thing that is going to
map all my routes and I could say I want
that to require authorization which this
is basically the equivalent of like the
authorize attribute from NBC what if I
could start sprinkling this stuff all
around different things and what solves
the problem about this or what problem
solved here that that I like is
something like health checks doesn't
know anything about authorization or
JSON exception handling or any of these
other kind of cross-cutting features it
just kind of come for free they're just
kind of part of the middleware pipeline
and then to kind of show I'm not going
to be able to tie it to show my whole
demo unfortunately but I want to show
one thing real quick which is I'm gonna
run this application and I'm going to
show you basically some of the same
information that we saw at the front and
I'm done that running because I can't
get Visual Studio to do this for
whatever reason so I'll figure that out
later but I'm going to show you the same
kind of information that we had before
when we had our list of actions and
things like that I don't know why this
is taking so long they would also like
me to remind you to please evaluate the
session on your way out thank you
I don't know why this is taking so long
there it goes okay so let's grab this
real quick the rest of my demo by the
way which I'm not going to be able to
get to unfortunately was to code up that
whole flow that you saw with the
exception handling Jason thing with
middleware and with the same set of
features with middleware and then be
able to also apply those kind of
policies with the same level of
granularity to both those lambdas and
health checks and your actions and all
that stuff in one system all with
middleware
so you can see you've got your home
controller you've got your endpoints
list and you've got all these other
lambda things here also listed with
their own metadata so you can see I've
got my adjacent exception metadata
actually beat here in fact I've got two
because I love it so we're starting to
have a lot of the same things that we
have with MVC but it's sort of a middle
layer kind of level and a more primitive
kind of level that like other frameworks
and other very low level things can take
advantage of so it's like kind of
sharing all the love of MVC out with the
world so anyway I'm going to have to end
there cuz I'm over time and I want to
let you guys have your break it's the
end so thank you very much for listening
and being good audience and please feel
free to reach out to me on Twitter or
github if you have questions or things
you want to talk about asp net asp net
core is always the best place to post
issues or ask questions and if you enjoy
the rest of the day
[Applause]
[Music]